okay you're actually still in your bank  president somebody else I'm suing else  see you Court judge  Your Honor I was born with an internal  clock I'm not gonna let them inside me  [Music]  Anya Adam check these bodies mrs. Adam  check do you swear solemnly if your  daughter was born with a rare  neurological condition that renders the  passage of time and enforced external  world judge please I just can't seem to  get go until later at night do you think  I want to be late  those people deserve a show you have no  idea the hell that I've been through I  am wishing there was any way on earth I  could get going I just don't think I'm  gonna make it I promised me mama when I  die have the coffin arrived half an hour  later on the side written in gold  letters of the words sorry for the delay  you